i
[Música]
ah
luego que presidente donald trump y su
esposa la primera dama dieran positivo a
la prueba de coronavirus los eventos que
estaban previstos para su campaña
presidencial se han cancelado para la
próxima semana también el vicepresidente
de mike pence e hizo la prueba al igual
que su esposa y dieron negativo a esto
ocurre después de que el mandatario
hubiera tenido contacto con miles de
personas en un evento en nueva york para
recaudar fondos y luego de que esta
semana también hubiera tenido contacto
con el candidato por el partido
demócrata a la presidencia yo bailé en
el primer debate presidencial la próxima
semana se darán cita kamala harris y
mike pence para este debate en yuta para
el camino a la reelección y también para
ver si los demócratas podrán llegar a la
casa blanca
[Música]
en eeuu la semana política arrancó con
ese primer debate electoral que puso de
manifiesto la situación polarizada en la
que se encuentra el país y la tensión
que hay después de ocho meses ya de
pandemia ambos candidatos se enfrentaron
durante 90 minutos y sin descanso en un
cuerpo a cuerpo y las encuestas dieron
por vencedor de la noche al demócrata
joe biden los expertos no esperaban
mucho de él y supo mantener el tipo ante
las provocaciones de donald trump sin
duda los perdedores de esta noche de
debate fueron los estadounidenses porque
fue imposible entender las propuestas de
ambos candidatos entre gritos
interrupciones e insultos no quedó claro
cómo iban a afrontar la terrible
situación económica que atraviesa el
país o cómo iban a hacer frente a la
pandemia que asola al mundo y por si
fuera poco la semana se cierra con el
anuncio de que donald tram ha dado
positivo en kobe 19 y esto cambia todo
porque no sabemos qué va a pasar en este
mes que queda hasta las elecciones como
va a ser la campaña a partir de ahora y
sobre todo qué va a ocurrir con esos dos
debates que están previstos para el
próximo 15
22 de septiembre
[Música]
después del primer debate increíble and
aquí en miami hay cierta expectación en
la comisión de debates presidenciales
había acordado junto a los dos
candidatos que el segundo encuentro
tendría lugar en el sur de la florida
pero ahora mismo hay una gran
incertidumbre después de que el
presidente de donald trump haya
cancelado todos sus actos de campaña
tras dar positivo por coronavirus
algunos dicen que es demasiado pronto
para saber cuáles van a ser los planes
para el próximo 14 de octubre fecha que
se había acordado el segundo debate una
de las opciones en caso de que trans no
pueda es que fuera en su lugar el
vicepresidente mike pence o que incluso
el mandatario apareciera vía telemática
por el momento no se puede descartar
nada si finalmente se celebra el debate
los temas que muy probablemente se
toquen sean en la cuestión de la crisis
en venezuela y la política exterior en
otros países de américa latina como cuba
y nicaragua la cuestión inmigratoria
podría ser otro de los temas que entren
en la agenda pero todo está por ver
[Música]